hello movie-going fans welcome two
reasons to see where I'm going to
provide you with movie news in three
minutes or less avengers age of ultron
open to 187 million dollars at the
domestic box office although age of
Ultron is made a [ __ ] ton of money this
is considered an embarrassment it's been
confirmed that Keanu Reeves will return
for John wick to in the sequel someone
kills his cat and he seeks revenge
that's not a real plot the first one is
dog was killed so I was making a funny
david error has released the first
official photo of the Suicide Squad if
you look from left to right these
characters are people i don't know
except for harley quinn and Will Smith
fresh off the underwhelming result of
Jupiter ascending netflix has announced
the Wachowski sci fi thriller sense8
will be coming to netflix you guys may
not know this but Lana Wachowski was
originally larry wachowski until he got
a sex change backs the first official
look of quinton Tarantino's the hateful
eight is featured on the front cover of
Entertainment Weekly Tarantino says the
film is like a cross between Django
Unchained and reservoir dogs this
confirms how egotistical Tarantino is
more exciting confirmed news regarding
captain america civil war ant-man's Paul
Rudd will appear as an nan Chadwick
Boseman will make his first appearance
as Black Panther and the hobbits Martin
Freeman will be playing a character to
you imagine if the Hobbit was actually
an Avenger novia was unnecessary Avenger
Ryan Phillippe a or Phillippe Villa but
doesn't matter cuz he's not really
famous anymore is meeting with marble
about a netflix series it's rumored that
it could be iron fist this is very
exciting for comic book wannabes who
want to pretend they know who iron fist
is
director of Captain Phillips in the
bourne ultimatum paul greengrass is set
to direct the biopic of jimi hendrix
this is exactly what we need a story
about a legendary musician that will
most likely be shot like a realistic
handheld documentary that is way too
intense for us to handle it should be
fun it's been announced that Avengers
infinity War part 1 and 2 will be filmed
with brand new IMAX cameras now if you
know me I love imax so this means i just
came in my pants that's it for the movie
news of the week that i thought was
really interesting if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects and you can also catch my videos
on Latino Review calm it is not just
targeted towards Latinas although i
think they feature me because they think
on latina regardless i reap the benefit
of being on their movie site so check
them out